.
Sie ist bereit.
* Ein Mann lacht. *
Wir hatten das Glück,
dass wir im Tessin ein
wunderschönes Haus kaufen konnten.
Es ist ein Haus aus den 70er-Jahren
und es gibt einiges zu tun.
Das Problem ist,
dass die gelieferten Steine
alle sehr klein waren.
Daher sagten wir: "Stopp,
so können wir nicht weitermachen."
(Fernsehsprecher) Hagelkörner
so gross wie Tennisbälle:
Das Locarnese wurde gestern
von einem Unwetter getroffen.
Die Wassermassen waren der Wahnsinn.
Hier stürzten Bäche herunter.
Noch 5 mm, dann ist es gut.
Yeah. Es hält.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Verträumte Schlagzeug-
und Gitarrenklänge *
Melanie und Markus Häfliger
leben in Solothurn,
zusammen mit der sieben Monate alten
Tochter Grace.
Der Name erinnert an den Ort,
wo die beiden geheiratet haben:
Maui auf Hawaii.
Reisen
ist eine Leidenschaft der zwei,
genauso wie die Liebe
zum Süden der Schweiz.
Und dort wollen sie nun ein lang-
ersehntes Projekt realisieren.
Wir haben das Glück,
dass wir im Tessin ein
wunderschönes Haus kaufen konnten
bzw. zwei Häuser,
ein Rustico gehört noch dazu.
Wir planen,
es umzubauen, zu renovieren.
Es ist ein Haus aus den 70er-Jahren
und es gibt einiges zu tun.
Es ist ein total spannendes Projekt,
weil man sieht,
was man aus Bestehendem machen kann,
um den Wunschzustand zu erreichen.
Das macht das Ganze sehr spannend.
Die Immobilie
befindet sich im Centovalli,
ein grosszügiges Grundstück
mit 5'000 m2 Umschwung.
Bis 2020
war das ein Sommerferienhaus.
Neben der Villa und dem kleinen Pool
gehört auch ein Rustico zum Ensemble.
Das diente früher als Ziegenstall.
Häfligers
planen eine sanfte Renovation,
erwarten jedoch
einen mehrmonatigen Umbau.
Sie haben lange gespart,
um sich den Traum vom eigenen Haus
im Süden zu erfüllen.
Mein Mann und ich
haben viel gearbeitet.
Da wir erst jetzt eine Tochter
haben, arbeiteten wir zuvor 100 %
und erwirtschafteten uns so
das Kapital für die Immobilie.
* Verträumte Gitarrenklänge *
Markus ist Ingenieur in Chemie.
Zuletzt hat er als Berater
für Pharmaunternehmen gearbeitet.
Melanie betreibt einen Onlinehandel
für Kosmetikprodukte.
Design interessiert sie seit jeher.
Darum wollen sie
die Bauarbeiten selbst managen.
Als wir das Objekt kauften,
hatten wir schon
relativ klare Vorstellungen,
was wir
designtechnisch machen wollen.
Daher wissen wir, was wir wollen.
Nun benötigen wir noch
die geeigneten Handwerker,
die uns dabei unterstützen.
Das ist eine ziemliche Challenge.
Punkto Budget haben wir etwas
mehr als 500'000 Fr. zur Verfügung.
Mein Mann machte eine Aufstellung.
Wo stehen wir mit dem Budget?
Also, aktuell ...
... sind wir noch
etwas über dem Budget.
Aber wir können
noch verschiedene Punkte optimieren,
auch in Bezug
auf die technischen Lösungen.
Daher bin ich
eigentlich guten Mutes.
Noch glauben die zwei fest daran,
dass sie die nötigen Absprachen
für den Bau
vorläufig aus der Ferne organisieren
können, von Solothurn aus.
Wir kommunizieren sehr viel
über Skype mit den Handwerkern.
Wenn die Bauphase beginnt,
werden wir wohl schon vor Ort sein,
sprich einige Wochen Ferien
dort unten verbringen,
damit wir täglich
auf der Baustelle sind.
* Sanfte Spieluhrmelodie *
Du darfst wirklich schlafen.
Ein grosser Tag:
Häfligers
sind heute ins Tessin gereist,
um den Vertrag mit
der Bauunternehmung zu unterzeichnen.
Buongiorno.
* Sie lacht. *
- (Mann) Buongiorno, piacere.
Buongiorno.
- Buongiorno.
Buongiorno, piacere.
Bitte, nehmen Sie Platz.
(Französisch) Wir haben die Chefin
hier für die Unterschrift.
Ah, sì?
* Der Mann lacht. *
Fantastisch.
Sie schaut genau.
- Sì, sì, sì.
Wollen Sie später hier leben?
Das Wetter und das Klima
wären ein Argument.
Le climat, le temps, et puis ...
Dann die Landschaft,
die Täler, der See ...- Sì, sì.
Sì, sì, sì.
Französisch ist sehr hilfreich.
Viele sprechen Französisch,
Deutsch z.T. auch,
Englisch ein bisschen
und natürlich Italienisch.
Aber mit Herrn Ferrari
und Herrn Cavalli
haben wir uns
auf Französisch geeinigt,
weil beide
sehr gut Französisch sprechen.
Das ist sehr angenehm
und geht etwas schneller,
als wenn wir alles
auf Italienisch besprechen müssten.
Aber das Technische,
die Verträge, die Offerten etc.
sind auf Italienisch.
Dieses Vokabular
haben wir bereits gut intus.
Das haben wir gelernt.
Hast du alles ausgedruckt,
Giorgio? Zeig mal.
Ja, jetzt noch die Stempel.
Nur mit der Ruhe.
Okay.
Sie ist bereit.
* Lachen *
Bisher war der längste Vertrag
mit AlpTransit.
Nein, der mit ASTRA war noch länger.
Ein Vertrag,
so detailliert und präzise,
dass er sogar erfahrene
Bauunternehmer beeindruckt,
die bereits Verträge
mit Baustellen wie der ASTRA
oder AlpTransit unterzeichneten.
Aber für Häfligers
ist Sicherheit wichtig.
Sie wissen:
Beim Bauen ist Unerwartetes
die Regel und nicht die Ausnahme.
Okay, bene.
- Perfetto.
Grazie.
Einer für euch und einer für uns.
Ecco, okay.
Jetzt können wir anfangen.
Endlich ist es so weit,
die Bauarbeiten haben begonnen.
Die Betreuung der Baustelle
fordert sie stark,
Markus ist fast täglich vor Ort
und ist zum Hauptansprechpartner
für die Bauarbeiter geworden.
Zu Beginn dachten wir,
wir könnten das Projekt
von zu Hause aus umsetzen.
Durch die Diskussionen
und die Reisen merkten wir,
dass es schwierig ist,
jemanden zu finden,
der die Problematiken
oder unsere Visionen versteht.
Deshalb entschlossen wir uns,
in der heissen Phase des Baus
möglichst oft oder fast permanent
vor Ort zu sein,
um das Gelingen des Projekts
sicherzustellen und dabei zu sein.
Darum haben sie in Ascona
eine kleine Wohnung gemietet.
Ciao.
- Wie geht's?
Alles in Ordnung.
Es geht vorwärts.
Wir machen Fortschritte.
- Sì, sì, sì.
Die Aussicht hier wird sehr schön.
Die Pflanze muss noch weg.
Die Idee ist,
ein grösseres Fenster einzubauen,
etwa so gross
wie die roten Linien hier.
Das Haus
hat vorn sehr viele Fenster.
Aber im hinteren Bereich
gab es nicht so viel Licht.
Daher bauen wir hier
ein schönes Panoramafenster ein.
Den neuen Eigentümern ist es wichtig,
den Stil des Hauses zu bewahren.
Das Haus hat durch das Holz,
den Stein und die Lage
extrem viel Charakter.
Das wollen wir sanft verändern
bzw. zu einem grossen Teil erhalten.
Wir finden es
wirklich traumhaft schön.
* Bohrlärm *
Wir wollen es auf einen möglichst
modernen Stand bringen,
es jedoch nicht komplett verändern.
* Bohrlärm *
Das ist fürs Baustellenalbum.
Es soll einen daran erinnern,
wie es aussah, bevor es fertig war.
* Mitreissender Bluessong *
Trotz dem Einsatz auf der Baustelle -
die Familie nimmt sich Zeit für einen
Abstecher ins nahe gelegene Ascona.
Das Städtchen
steht ganz im Zeichen von Musik,
das jährliche Jazzfestival
hat eben begonnen.
* Mitreissender Bluessong *
Wir kennen Ascona
schon seit unserer Kindheit.
Wir waren beide
oft im Tessin in den Ferien.
Dadurch kennen wir
das Tessin relativ gut.
Die Stimmung ist gelöst
und Grace findet gerade neue Freunde.
Ciao.
- Ciao.
So eine Süsse.
Wollt ihr etwas mit uns trinken?
Sì, gerne.
- Versteht ihr mich?
Äh, un poco.
- Schweizerdeutsch?- Ja.
Willkommen, das ist gut.
- Danke.- Danke.
Kennt ihr Ascona bereits?
Uns gefällt v.a. das schöne Wetter
und die Italianità,
die das Tessin versprüht.
Die Menschen hier
sind sehr kinderlieb.
Das gefällt uns,
weil wir eine Tochter haben.
Zudem mögen wir das gute Essen.
Das ist
etwas sehr Zentrales für uns.
Wie habt ihr das Haus gefunden?
Durch ein Inserat?
Wir fanden es über einen Freund.
Es ist lustig:
Er hat ein Airbnb hier in Orselina.
Wir beschlossen, ihn mal anzurufen,
und irgendwie
sind wir dann Freunde geworden.
Ein Freund von ihm
hat uns das Haus verkauft.
Wollt ihr konstant hier leben?
Das wissen wir noch nicht.
Wir schauen, wie es sich ergibt.
Wir verbringen erst mal
den Sommer hier.- Ah, gut.
Ma cara.
Sie ist eine Süsse.
* Melanie lacht. *
Zum Wohl.
- Prost. Einen schönen Aufenthalt.
Danke.
- Salute.
Salute.
- Danke. Salute.
Danke für die spontane Einladung.
Hier ist alles etwas spontaner.
* Verträumte Gitarrenklänge *
Mama war schneller, was?
So, jetzt schauen wir,
was heute passiert ist.
Hier ist es besser mit der Kleinen.
Soll ich vorangehen
und es mir ansehen?- Mhm.
* Verträumte Gitarrenklänge *
So.
Buongiorno.
- Ciao, Andrea.
Ah, da ist ja die Kleine.
- Genau, die Kleine.
Na? Winkst du Andrea?
- Ciao.
Zeigst du ihr das Haus?
- Sì.
Wir schauen uns die Fortschritte an.
Machen wir eine kleine Runde.
- Willst du noch hochgehen?
Ja, wir gehen kurz hoch.
* Babygeräusche *
Oi.
Che bello.
- Ja, das sieht cool aus.
Das sorgt für richtig viel Licht.
Gestern hatten sie knapp die Hälfte.
- Ja.
Jetzt
kann man es sich gut vorstellen.
Es ist viel grosszügiger
als mit dem kleinen Fenster.- Ja.
Es wirkt ganz anders.
- Ja.
Wenn hier noch die Mauer weg ist
und es ins schöne Treppenhaus führt,
ist es top.
Das war eine gute Entscheidung.
- Mhm.
Ganz viel Platz.
- Hier oben ist das Kinderzimmer.
Hier im Dachstock
soll Grace ihr Zimmer bekommen.
Um mehr Raum zu schaffen,
mussten Stützmauern weg.
Im Moment trägt
ein provisorischer Balken das Dach.
Dieser wird später durch eine
ausgeklügelte Konstruktion ersetzt,
an der das Dach aufgehängt wird.
* Babygeräusche *
Wollen wir rausgehen?
Uns war es wichtig, dass es
keine Dachkammer mehr ist wie zuvor.
Hier waren noch Wände
und es war sehr dunkel.
Wir wollten es offen gestalten,
damit sie Platz zum Schlafen
und Spielen hat.
Wir bauten auch Fenster ein,
damit es lichtdurchflutet ist
und ein gutes Raumgefühl entsteht.
Auch wenn die Arbeiten
bisher gut vorangehen:
Die Bauorganisation
ist aufwendig und zeitraubend.
Das alles neben den beruflichen
und familiären Verpflichtungen
zu bewältigen, zehrt an den Kräften.
Es gab schon immer wieder Momente,
in denen wir pausierten,
weil wir einfach
keine Energie mehr hatten.
Aber unser Traum
stand immer im Vordergrund
und trieb uns an, weiterzumachen.
Wir stellten es uns einfacher vor.
Schönes Wochenende.
- Ihnen auch.
Bis nächste Woche,
schönes Wochenende.
Ciao.
- Ciao, ciao.
* Verträumte Gitarrenklänge *
Das ist unser zweites Haus,
das Rustico.
Da muss noch
etwas mehr Arbeit reinfliessen,
aber wenn wir es schaffen,
wird es schön.
Mit den Reben davor
sieht es traumhaft aus.- Ja.
* Verträumte Gitarrenklänge *
* Grillenzirpen,
romantische Gitarrenklänge *
* Die Musik klingt aus. *
Ortstermin in Losone.
Markus und Melanie
wollen heute die Steine für den Boden
im Erdgeschoss auswählen.
Eine wichtige Entscheidung,
die sorgfältig abgewogen sein will.
Zum Glück ist sich das Paar
meistens rasch einig.
Hier ist das Muster des Luserna.
Sie möchten ja, dass er
in Mosaikform verlegt wird.- Genau.
Diese gespaltene Oberfläche
ist sehr typisch.
Das sieht wunderschön aus,
nicht wahr?
Ja, das, was wir suchten.
- Wirklich toll.
Wir suchten eine Weile,
bis wir den Stein fanden,
den wir uns vorgestellt hatten.
Toll, dass Sie ihn anhand
eines Fotos ausfindig machten.
Diese Aufgabe
war nicht ganz einfach,
aber das ist genau das,
was uns gefällt.
Wollen wir nochmals
darüber diskutieren?- Ja.
Design hat mich
schon immer fasziniert.
Mein Mann und ich haben beide ein
Auge fürs Schöne, fürs Ästhetische.
In letzter Zeit haben wir uns
intensiv weitergebildet.
Mein Mann und ich sind
sehr viel gereist, v.a. in den USA,
und waren oft in Airbnbs unterwegs.
Dort liessen wir uns von
verschiedenen Stilen inspirieren.
* Entspannte Gitarrenklänge *
In ihrem temporären Zuhause in Ascona
finden sie Zeit,
im Fotoalbum der Vorbesitzer
zu blättern.
Das ist schon verrückt, was?
Hier sieht man, wie sie
die Baustellenzufahrt machten.
Dieselbe Strasse, wie wir sie haben.
- Noch grösser als unsere Zufahrt.
Das ist schon eindrücklich.
Sie spitzten den Fels heraus.
- Sie brachen Steine heraus.
Man sieht, dass sie weniger
Hilfsmittel hatten als heute,
aber ein Förderband für
den Abtransport hatten sie schon.
Hier sieht man den Wald,
den es heute nicht mehr gibt.
Heute gibt es viel weniger Bäume.
- Wahnsinn.
Mhm, eine extreme Veränderung.
Hier sieht man sogar
noch die Vorbesitzer.
Es ist toll, dass wir es
aus erster Hand übernehmen konnten
und wissen, wer es gebaut hat.
Für mich ist es schon wichtig,
zu wissen, wer zuvor dort wohnte
und welchen Geist das Haus hat.
Beim Betreten des Hauses
spürte man, dass es ein gutes ...
... eine gute Energie ...
- ... herrschte.
Als wir die Besitzer
persönlich kennenlernten,
bestätigte sich unser Eindruck.
Wir mussten hier
ein Häuschen mieten,
was doppelte Mietkosten bedeutet,
aber bei den Fenstern
konnten wir z.B. viel einsparen.
Anfangs wurde uns
zu Holzfenstern geraten,
weil man das Haus sieht und
es in einer speziellen Zone liegt.
Ich sagte zu meinem Mann, dass
ich das noch richtig abklären will,
weil man ja weiss,
dass Holzfenster am teuersten sind.
Für die Holzfenster hatten wir
ein Angebot von 120'000 Fr.
und mussten schlucken,
weil das viel Geld ist.
Mein Mann tätigte einen Anruf
bei der Baubehörde und diese sagte,
da man unser Haus
von der Strasse aus gar nicht sehe,
spiele es keine Rolle,
welche Fenster wir einbauen würden.
Daher entschieden wir uns für
etwas anderes und sind glücklich,
dass wir bei etwas mehr als der
Hälfte dieses Betrags gelandet sind.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Endlich ist es so weit:
Das Dach wird
mithilfe einer Stahlkonstruktion,
die normalerweise für Hängebrücken
verwendet wird, aufgehängt.
So ist das Gewicht des Daches
auf die Aussenwände verteilt.
Das ist nötig, weil
die tragende Mauer entfernt wurde.
Jetzt können wir anfangen,
die Struktur zu montieren.
Zuerst
machen wir eine Niveaukontrolle.
Leg du den Meter hierhin,
ich kontrolliere
die Höhe des Trägers.
Ja, ich sehe es: 79,4.
Wir schauen dann,
nachdem wir es gespannt haben.
Gut, dann fangen wir jetzt an.
Ein paar Erinnerungen.
Das hier ist das zentrale Element.
Jetzt noch
die Verankerungselemente montieren.
Wenn alles befestigt ist, ist es,
als ob der Träger so hoch wäre.
Von hier bis dort, etwa 70 cm.
Wir gewinnen ziemlich an Höhe.
Der Raum unter dem Dach
wird viel grösser.
Das hier ist schon aussergewöhnlich
und wir mussten
eine Weile darüber nachdenken.
Vielleicht
können wir es erneut anwenden,
wenn Herr Häfliger wieder
eine Konstruktion machen möchte.
Jede dieser Gewindestangen aus Stahl
trägt eine Last von 5'000 kg,
sobald das System aktiviert ist.
E poi anche in mezzo.
- Ci siamo.
In mezzo deve andare dentro ...
- Entro prima io. Un attimo.
Ecco. Aspetta.
Qui ci siamo.
- Okay.
Così va bene.
Quando lo mando in tensione
va contro. - Sì, sì, sì.
Mit den Stahlseilen, die das tragen,
haben wir eine Golden Gate Bridge.
Das haben wir gemessen,
um die Struktur zu kontrollieren.
Andrea hat die Zahl
dann auf den Balken geschrieben.
Genau, das lassen wir so,
als Erinnerung.
Wie Caravaggio.
Wir machen so eine kleine ...
(Französisch) Wir machen
eine kleine Plakette: "Caravaggio".
Wir schreiben:
"Hier hat er unterschrieben."
Genau.
"Im Namen des Herrn, im Jahr ..."
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Ist es leicht gespannt?
Ja. Wir ziehen es 5 mm hoch.
- Oui.
Sobald die Stangen verschraubt sind,
können die Stützen,
die das Dach tragen, entfernt werden.
Si sta alzando.
Noch 5 mm, dann ist es gut.
Jetzt hat es sich schon
um 3 mm gehoben.
Die Spannung steigt.
Spannung.
Perfekt, es hat sich nicht bewegt,
gut. Es funktioniert.
Yeah. Es hält.
Es sieht wirklich schön aus.
Wir haben keinen Champagner,
aber wir können ein Foto machen.
Mauro, machst du ein Foto
von uns unter dem Balken?
Nun machen wir es offiziell.
Lächeln, bitte.
Wegen der Stahlseile,
die das Ganze tragen,
gaben wir ihm den Spitznamen
Golden Gate Bridge,
weil sie ein Sinnbild für Stahlseile
und Drahtkonstruktionen ist.
Das liess das Technikerherz
in mir höherschlagen
und das Ästhetenherz auch,
weil wir aus den kleinen Räumen
ein schönes Zimmer für Grace
machen konnten.
* Entspannte Gitarrenklänge *
Die Dachkonstruktion hält -
Zeit für ein wenig Entspannung.
Der 46-Jährige möchte herausfinden,
wer sich
auf seinem Grundstück tummelt,
wenn die Bauarbeiter
Feierabend haben.
Es wäre natürlich schön, wenn
wir einige der nächtlichen Besucher
auf Kamera bannen könnten.
Ich sah schon öfter Spuren.
Es könnten Wildschweine sein,
und Mario sagte,
es gäbe auch Dachse.
Es wäre cool, wenn wir
auf der Kamera sehen könnten,
was sie nachts hier machen und
wie sie übers Grundstück huschen.
Mal sehen, ob sie Beeren mögen.
* Entspannte Gitarrenklänge *
Das ist vielleicht
gar kein schlechter Ort.
Ich glaube,
dort drüben ist es besser.
Ich muss einen Ort finden,
wo ich sie festmachen kann.
Hier kann ich sie
nicht so gut befestigen.
Nachdem ich mich in der Freizeit
mit dem Aufstellen der Wildkameras
beschäftigt habe,
gehe ich nun wieder an die Arbeit.
Jetzt schaue ich, wie es läuft
und was wir noch besprechen müssen.
* Nachrichtensignet aus dem Radio *
(Nachrichtensprecherin)
Il Radiogiornale.
(Nachrichtensprecher)
Ab heute bis zum 16. August
sind im Tessin die traditionellen
Sommerferien fürs Baugewerbe.
Zwei Wochen
dauert die obligatorische Sommerpause
auf allen Baustellen im Tessin:
Ferragosto heisst das hier.
Etwas, das man in der Deutschschweiz
so nicht kennt.
Ferragosto
ist schon eine Zwangspause.
Man würde gern weitermachen.
Es sind so viele Dinge in Gang
und plötzlich steht alles still.
Das machte uns
einen Strich durch die Rechnung.
Ein Teil der Arbeiten
konnte nicht durchgeführt werden,
da die Firma keine Zeit hatte,
das noch vorher zu erledigen.
Es tut mir leid, jetzt zuzumachen.
Es ist das erste Mal,
dass mir das passiert.
Ich sehe die ganze Arbeit,
was es noch alles zu tun gibt.
Wenn wir zurückkommen, müssen wir
alles neu planen - mühsam.
So ist es halt.
Danke für alles.
Schöne Ferien und gute Erholung.
Grazie mille, danke, ciao.
- Grazie.
Schotten dicht, die Baustelle ...
... pausiert.
* Entspannte Gitarrenklänge *
Rasa ist ein kleines schmuckes Dorf
im Centovalli, das einzige im Tessin,
das keine Strasse hat.
Das Dorf ist nur mit der Seilbahn
oder in einer guten Stunde Fussmarsch
zu erreichen -
ein beliebtes Ausflugsziel.
* Entspannte Musik *
Zu den Ziegen rein.
* Sie lacht. *
Hei, schau.
- Ei, hast du gesehen?
Kaninchen gibt es auch.
Für uns war es klar,
dass wir eher später Kinder wollen.
Davor sind wir viel gereist und
konnten uns beruflich verwirklichen.
Nun haben wir das Privileg,
voll und ganz für unsere Tochter
da sein zu können.
Wir können diese Zeit
wirklich geniessen,
ohne finanzielle, berufliche
oder andere Sorgen zu haben.
* Eine Ziege meckert. *
Jetzt schliessen wir das Tor.
* Grace macht freudige Geräusche,
Markus lacht. *
Für die 43-Jährige und ihren Mann
ist die Familienplanung
noch nicht abgeschlossen.
Vielleicht kommt für Grace
noch ein Geschwisterchen dazu.
Die beiden gefallen dir, was?
Da.
Das Huhn kommt wieder runter.
Es wollte doch nicht rein.
* Entspannte Musik *
Es tut gut,
ein bisschen den Kopf durchzulüften,
einfach mal draussen
in der Natur zu sein
und sich nicht zu viele Gedanken
über das Projekt zu machen.
Wir hatten Spass mit der Kleinen.
Die Tiere haben ihr wirklich
gefallen, nicht wahr?
* Entspannte Musik *
* Verträumte Gitarrenklänge *
Das können wir offen lassen,
nicht wahr?
Mal sehen, ob wir mit der Kamera
etwas einfangen konnten.
Ich bin gespannt,
ob ein paar Tiere vorbeikamen.
* Verträumte Gitarrenklänge *
* Grace macht freudige Geräusche. *
Hast du das Reh gesehen, Grace?
Oh.
Das könnte ein Wildschwein sein.
Das müssen wir uns genauer ansehen.
Siehst du die Ohren?
- Was es hier alles gibt.
Ja. Siehst du?
Hei, das ist ein Schweinchen.
Wir haben Schweinchen hier.
- Hier ist es wieder.
Siehst du das Schwänzchen?
- (Staunend) Oh.
He.
Süss.
- Ein Wildschweinchen.
Es kam mehrmals vorbei.
Hast du das Reh gesehen?
- Oh, ist das schön.
Es sieht total süss aus.
- Oh.
Es sieht aus wie bei Harry Potter.
- Genau.
* Grace macht freudige Geräusche. *
Oi.
Das ist die reinste Fotoshow. Na?
Nachts kommt ein halber Zoo vorbei.
- Unglaublich.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht,
dass so viele vorbeikommen.
dass es hier Rehe gibt.
Sie können dort oben
über die Mauer springen
und dort unten sind Beeren,
Brombeeren.
Wahrscheinlich frassen sie die.
Wow, das ist eine gute Ausbeute.
Die Familie scheint ihr kleines
Paradies gefunden zu haben,
mitten im Grünen, unweit vom See.
* Nachrichtensignet *
(Nachrichtensprecher) Hagelkörner
so gross wie Tennisbälle.
Das Locarnese wurde gestern
von einem Unwetter getroffen.
Menschen wurden verletzt,
Autos zerstört,
Fenster zerschlagen und die Schulen
in Losone schwer beschädigt.
Der heftige Sturm richtete Schäden in
der Höhe von mehreren 10 Mio. Fr. an.
Häfligers
kamen mit einem blauen Auge davon.
Keine Hagelschäden, aber der
starke Regen flutete auch ihr Haus.
Da es in Hanglage steht,
haben Regenfälle
noch eine dramatischere Auswirkung.
Markus zeigt einem Freund,
was das Unwetter verursacht hat.
Es gibt trotzdem ein paar Dinge,
die man nicht voraussehen kann.
Hier ist der Keller.
Darin war Wasser.
War es viel Wasser?
- Die Wassermassen waren extrem.
Es liefen Bäche den Hang runter.
- War etwa so viel Wasser drin?
Ja, drinnen war etwa so viel Wasser.
Der Schacht
wurde mit Erdreich gefüllt
und dann drückte alles herein.
Diese Fläche reicht bereits,
damit es hier unten ...
Das reicht?
- Ja, ja, das ist der Wahnsinn.
Mit dem befreundeten Ingenieur begut-
achtet Markus das Abwassersystem.
Die Regenfälle haben sich
in den letzten Jahren verstärkt,
immer öfter
fallen die Mengen extrem aus
und überfordern das bisherige System.
Neu soll das Wasser seitlich dem Haus
entlang abgeleitet werden.
Eine Drainageschicht
und dann vom Haus weg.
In die neue Leitung,
die wir hier rüberziehen.
Auch das Wasser vom Dach.
Aber hier kommt richtig ...
- Das ist viel, was?
Hier kommt richtig viel Wasser.
Das sahen wir,
als wir das Laub entfernten.
Wir mussten ein 15er-Rohr verwenden.
Es ist schon viel Arbeit.
Wenn es nicht nötig ist,
lässt man es, aber so ist es besser.
Oft kommt oft.
Das war nicht vorgesehen, aber
wir machen es jetzt lieber richtig,
als es danach lange zu bereuen.
Dass das Wasser
eine solche Problematik
für das Haus darstellen könnte,
wussten wir nicht
und berechneten es nicht ein.
Nun ist es
eine ziemliche Herausforderung,
das Abwassersystem
im Budget unterzubringen,
damit das Ganze
in Zukunft gut geregelt
und das Haus optimal
vor dem Wasser geschützt ist.
Die Drainage verursacht
Mehrkosten von mehreren 10'000 Fr.
Zum Glück haben sie
einen Budgetposten Unvorhergesehenes.
Nicht nur das Haus, auch das Rustico
möchten Häfligers restaurieren.
Sie wollen
eine Ferienwohnung einrichten.
Das Haus ist eigentlich
schon fast fertig,
aber beim Rustico
ist leider noch nichts passiert.
Das hat einen Grund: Wir warten
immer noch auf die Baubewilligung.
Wir reichten sie gleichzeitig ein
wie die Baubewilligung fürs Haus,
aber bei einem Rustico gibt es
mehr Auflagen als bei einem Haus.
Wir erhielten
etwa zwei A4-Seiten mit Auflagen.
Bei diesem Rustico
haben wir die Auflage,
dass es
nur ein Steindach haben darf.
Wir dachten an ein Ziegeldach -
das ist definitiv günstiger -,
aber der Kanton
sagte ganz klar Nein.
Wir müssen ein Steindach anbringen.
Wir müssen das Dach
sowieso reparieren,
da sonst Einsturzgefahr besteht.
Wenn es einstürzen würde,
dürften wir es nicht entfernen.
Das wollen wir
auf jeden Fall verhindern.
Es wäre schade ums Rustico
und wir würden vom Haus aus
ständig einen Steinberg sehen.
Wir möchten es bewohnbar machen.
* Entspannte Gitarrenklänge *
Das Ehepaar
beschäftigte sich eingehend
mit dem Design der Möbel
und der Küche.
In Ascona
fanden sie eine Schreinerei,
die ihre Wünsche umsetzt.
Nun besprechen wir
mit Roberto unsere Küche.
Wir schauen uns Materialien an.
Er hat Materialmuster für uns.
Jetzt sind wir gespannt.
Also, gehen wir ins Detail?
Hier soll ein Kühlschrank stehen,
nicht wahr?- Mhm.
Hier haben wir 20 cm Platz
für einen kleinen Schrank.- Mhm.
Hier habe ich ein Muster
für die Aussenseite erstellt.
Mein Ziel ist eigentlich,
dass ich so weitermachen kann.
Vielleicht - das muss ich sagen -
werden es nicht genau 60,
sondern etwas mehr sein.
Aber ich versuche,
jede Front so abzuschliessen.
Uns war es wichtig,
runde Ecken zu haben.
Wir haben eine Kochinsel
mit runden Ecken
und Badezimmermöbel
mit runden Ecken.
Das zieht sich durchs ganze Haus.
Es war eine ziemliche Challenge,
v.a. mit dem Material, das wir
hier sehen, das so hinzukriegen.
Nun müsst ihr es euch anschauen.
Schön.
- Das sieht cool aus.
Ich habe noch ein Muster erstellt.
Oh, wow.
Wir haben beide eine Affinität
zu James-Bond-Filmen,
v.a. wegen der Architektur.
Wir liessen uns stark
durch die Filme inspirieren.
Der Steinboden
ist ein Beispiel dafür
und wir nahmen das Thema
teils in den Möbeln wieder auf.
"Im Geheimdienst Ihrer Majestät"
spielt auf dem Schilthorn
und dort sahen wir
das Geländer für die Treppe.
Das hat uns
in Bezug auf unser Haus inspiriert.
Wir wollten es
sehr ähnlich gestalten.
Eigentlich müssten die Arbeiter
jetzt weiter Steinplatten verlegen,
aber stattdessen
reinigen sie den Boden.
Stillstand auf der Baustelle.
Das Problem ist,
dass die gelieferten Steine
alle sehr klein waren.
Auch die Plattenleger sagten,
dass das Muster dadurch
ganz anders werden würde als das,
was wir ursprünglich geplant hatten.
Daher sagten wir: "Stopp,
so können wir nicht weitermachen."
Wir müssen nochmals
mit dem Lieferanten abklären,
wieso die Steine kleiner sind als
die, die ursprünglich geplant waren.
Das war
eine etwas anstrengende Diskussion.
Aber wir hoffen,
dass wir Ende nächste Woche
die Steine erhalten, die wir wollen.
Die Lieferverzögerung
löst eine Kettenreaktion aus.
Alle weiteren Arbeiten
verschieben sich ebenfalls
um beinahe drei Wochen.
Die Renovation des Hauses
dauert nun bereits fast fünf Monate.
Gleich lange,
wie die Vorbesitzer für den Bau
der ganzen Villa gebraucht haben.
Langsam macht sich Ungeduld breit.
Wie eine Grosse.
Wir würden natürlich
am liebsten sofort einziehen.
Aber es ist ein Ende in Sicht.
Das ist gut.
Zurzeit leben wir
in einer sehr kleinen Wohnung
und da es kühler wird,
sind wir mehr drinnen.
Wir freuen uns aufs Haus,
wo wir mehr Platz und Komfort haben.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Mitte November ist es dann so weit:
Die Häfligers
stehen kurz vor dem Einzug.
Die meisten Arbeiten
sind abgeschlossen.
Wow!
Das habe ich noch gar nicht gesehen.
Ja, hier ist einiges passiert.
Das ist wunderschönes Holz.
Das wird genial.
Die Holzstruktur
passt gut zu den abgerundeten Ecken.
Echt schön. Und das Cheminée
ist natürlich auch ein Highlight.
Man sieht es vom Wohnzimmer aus.
Man sieht es vom Wohnzimmer
und vom Esstisch aus.
Solange es noch eine Baustelle
und im Rohbau war,
war es nicht so richtig greifbar.
Jetzt stehen wir kurz vor dem Einzug
und es wird greifbar.
Man sieht das Resultat.
Das macht extrem viel Freude.
Eine intensive Zeit
liegt hinter ihnen.
Eine Zeit,
die sie auch als Paar verändert hat.
Es benötigt natürlich schon
viel Energie und viel Zeit.
Aber wenn man ein gutes Team ist,
dann schafft man das.
Ich denke, es hat uns ...
... näher zusammengebracht.
- ... noch stärker gemacht.
Aus den ehemals engen Räumlichkeiten
sind offene, lichtdurchflutete Räume
entstanden.
* Entspannte Gitarrenklänge *
Und die dunkelbraunen Möbel
wurden durch helle ersetzt.
Besonderer Hingucker:
das freischwebende Cheminée.
Das Cheminée
ist wunderschön geworden.
Genau so haben sich die Häfligers
ihr Traumhaus vorgestellt.
Essen wir noch Panettone?
Während des Umbaus ist auch
eine neue berufliche Vision gereift.
Das wollen wir auch in Zukunft
für andere Leute machen:
schönen Objekten
neues Leben einhauchen
und die Menschen beim Innenausbau,
beim Design
und beim Umbau unterstützen,
um solche schönen Projekte
zu realisieren.
* Verträumte Gitarrenklänge *
Ist der Kuchen lecker?
Es ist ein super Gefühl,
v.a. weil es
so geworden ist bzw. wird,
wie wir es uns vorgestellt haben.
Es ist ein schönes Glücksgefühl. Die
Anstrengungen haben sich gelohnt.
Cheers.
- Auf den Einzug.
Wohin sie ihre Reise führt,
ist offen.
Ob als Ferienhausvermieter
oder Umbauspezialisten -
ihr Glück im Süden haben Häfligers
auf jeden Fall gefunden.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023